اذا التغطيه مستمره معكم وهذه التغطيه
المفتوحه والتي بداناها في صباح العربيه
وستستمر طوال هذا اليوم فعلا بطل عليكم كل
يوم في صباح العربيه لمده ساعتين لكن خلف
الساعتين عمل على مدار الساعه سندخلكم
الان في كواليس صباح العربيه كيف تصنع
الحلقه من الفكره الاولى الى لحظه البث
الاولى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
صباح العربي البرنامج الصباحي الاضخم في
الوطن العربي يطرح مواضيع مختلفه بطريقه
مبتكره تجاره قنبله نوويه صغيره
ولكن من هو الفريق وراء صباح العربيه
نتعرف عليهم من خلف الكواليس
الحكايه تبدا من هذه الغرفه حيث تصنع
الافكار تطرح في الاجتماع ونتفق على خطه
سير المواضيع واحيانا لا نتفق
[موسيقى]
وهنا ينقسم الفريق الى فريق المحتوى وفريق
الانتاج ونبدا بالكتابه والانتاج والتواصل
والبحث عن الضيوف
وفي تمام الساعه الخامسه بتوقيت جرينتش
يبدا البث وتبدا اللحظه التي يعمل عليها
الفريق على مدار ال 24 ساعه
[تصفيق]
ونكمل العمل
نودعكم هنا لكننا مستمرون وسنكون على
الموعد دائما